good afternoon everyone welcome to the
daily briefing I do not have anything at
the top so i will go to your questions
just go through for us the phone calls
that the Secretary had yesterday and any
that he might have had today
specifically related to Syria absolutely
yesterday the secretary spoke with the
UN Secretary General Ban ki-moon with
the Arab League secretary-general all
our abhi with EU High Representative
Ashton with the Egyptian Foreign
Minister Fahmy with Turkish Foreign
Minister Davao too low and Marathi
foreign minister abdullah bin ziyad
Saudi foreign minister Saud al-faisal
nato secretary general Rasmussen cuttery
foreign minister alisya two calls with
Jordanian foreign minister Judeh a call
with the UK foreign secretary Hague and
another call excuse me with the Arab
League secretary-general those were all
yesterday so sorry yesterday too with el
Arabi correct yes and to live with Judah
than one each with the others correct
yes and then today so far on my list and
just for planning purposes I think for a
few days we'll send an update at the end
of the day with all of the list of calls
that were that we're doing on this but
so far today he's spoken with the
Russian Foreign Minister Lavrov and with
the Moroccan foreign minister as well
okay could I just ask could you make an
exception to that end of the day
grouping if he happens to call Assad or
wollam okay thank you you've seen the
Arab League statement from this morning
I'm wondering what you have if you have
any reaction response to it yes well I
think it was a very strong statement
that made a few points and let me pull
those up right now I know you all have
seen it as well sharply condemn the use
of banned chemical weapons as something
of course that we agree with called for
holding the Syrian regime fully
responsible for this crime and I think
it would be important to say at the top
that we believe that any careful review
of the facts in the situation leads to
the conclusion that the regime was in
fact behind this horrific chemical
weapons attack it's undeniable that
chemical weapons were used here on a
large scale we know that the regime
maintains custody of those weapons and
uses these types of rockets and we also
know that the opposition does not
have those capabilities will have
additional information forthcoming from
the intelligence community in the days
to come on this assessment would you say
that in the Secretary's phone calls
yesterday and the one today with the
Moroccan I mean Paul's yesterday
particularly to the Arab foreign
ministers and to el Arabi that that this
statement or the media the meeting that
the statement emanated from was a was a
subject of conversation I don't know if
the statement was the subject of their
conversation of the meeting I don't know
if the meetings but specifically I know
the Arab League remains in emergency
session the secretary in all of these
calls has been discussing clearly the
assessments that we're undertaking and
how we was some point be making a
decision about a response I don't have
more specifics in terms of those calls
okay so I'm just do you have I mean you
said it was a very strong statement or
you is the administration pleased with
what the what the Arab League have to
say I think we both when it comes to the
Arab League but anybody else would
encourage people and organizations to
make strong statements condemning the
use of chemical weapons in this case in
all others what let me just put it I
just I just got one more on this
understatement and then at least
continue the statement also surged the
called on the Security Council to
overcome its differences members of the
Security Council to overcome their
differences and to take deterrent action
against this is this something the
United States feels is necessary before
any kind of a response is is implemented
well I would underscore against say that
the president has not yet made a
decision I don't know good okay thank
you I would underscore that the
president has not yet made a decision
yet so I'm not going to hypothetically
talk about what may or what may or may
not be part of that decision I know
there are a lot of rumors out there
about whether we'll take action ayer
action be and what that might entail
clearly the secretary and the president
and others remain in close consultation
with our international partners and
allies I we've read out a lot of those
calls that consultation will continue
I'm not asking what the response is
going to be but in the range of
responses that the administration is
considering do any would any of them in
the opinion of the administration of
require action by the UN Security
Council I'm not going to answer that
question one way or the other before the
president's made a decision okay so on
this statement did you was this
statement kind of formulated as a result
of you sharing because they they clearly
hold the regime accountable holding the
regime fully accountable for this
horrible crime was that were you sharing
your intelligence assessments that you
said you'll share with the public have
you been sharing those intelligence
assessments with the arab league as they
formulated their statement that was very
you know kind of undoubtedly pointing
the finger at the regime what i would
say a couple points broadly speaking we
are sharing our assessment with our
allies and partners around the world as
we make them i don't know to be honest
with you if that was part of what went
into the Arab League statement I think
you'd have to check with them about what
helped them formulate their statement
but i think it's crystal clear to
anybody looking at this that the regime
was responsible here we're still clear
circumstantially but it would have to
you as you said that you would put out
your intelligence assessment that would
prove what you're saying is undeniable
so I mean I guess we'll be waiting for
that but my question is did you ask the
Arab League to issue some kind of
statement that would show that the Arabs
hold the regime accountable for that
well clearly the Arab League makes
decisions I out of statement what did
you sit can I finish yeah sure okay
thank you clearly the Arab leak makes
decisions about its statements on its
own we have called publicly and
privately on everybody to strongly
condemn what happened in Syria and to
make it clear that we need to hold the
regime accountable so I'm not going to
specifically outline what the
Secretary's discussions abour with the
Secretary General other than to say that
clearly we call on people and
organizations around the world to make
such strong finger do you see this
statement as an endorsement of or in
support of any action that you say that
you you say that there will be a
response correct um do you
see this as a call by the Arab League
for some kind of international response
I said well they very clearly said that
they need the regime needed to be held
accountable and we've been said that we
will respond appropriately as the
president makes the decision so I think
that is pretty crystal clear in their
statement so so if the US were to take a
response then you see this Arab
statement as a kind of I don't want to
say green light but I think you're
taking it a step further the president
hasn't made a decision yet and I would
hasn't made a decision on what he's
going to do but but secretary Kerry
secretary Hagel talking about they're
ready to go like that it's pretty clear
that the administration is kind of
putting out there that there is going to
be some kind of response whether its
military I'm saying there's going to be
a response nobody else hiding that what
I was going to say before you
interrupted me was that the president
hasn't made a decision yet I wouldn't
read into this Arab League statement
specific endorsement of a specific
decision that has not yet been made well
that's a step further made to do
something correct but the decision about
what has not yet been made this is a any
kind of legal support from the Arab
League I'm not going to do any sort of
legal analysis today about a
hypothetical decision that has yet to be
made yes exactly this was the secretary
meeting with the president this morning
um not to my knowledge I can double
check on his schedule okay analogous
then um we really remains let me just
say clearly remains in close contact
with senior officials in the White House
and if we have any meetings to read out
or the White House has to read out we
can do so it was the what was the reason
for postponing that meeting with the
Russians do you feel that there is just
nothing to be said right now on the
political process that a response is
imminent or not you're worth that a
responses to be soon and that just has
to be on hold for now and that you
wouldn't make any gains from a meeting
like that well given our ongoing
consultations about an appropriate
response to that the chemical weapons
attack we have decided to postpone this
week meeting that was supposed to happen
in The Hague we wanted to happen at the
time when we have the best chance to
make progress we are working now with
the Russians to reschedule it I would
underscore strongly that this is only a
postponement it
not a cancellation of the meeting and I
think that what happened on august
twenty-first only underscores the need
for a political solution and we remain
fully invested in in a comprehensive and
durable political solution to the crisis
in Syria because we continue to believe
that there's no military solution to
this crisis so we kind of message would
you be standing by you know cutting
ourselves because some people think that
you see that you should keep the
diplomatic lines open I'm clearly their
calls but there's nothing better than
face-to-face meeting well as I said the
secretary spoke with the Russian Foreign
Minister today so his level of
consultation on this issue is is quite
high and sustained and will continue to
be we did not believe that this was the
right timing for this meeting but again
we are working right now with the
Russians to reschedule it at a time that
makes more sense hopefully in the very
near future and will continue working
with Russia and our international
partners again because we are fully
invested in this process very on your
own malicious point I mean surely it's
very important because there's a
precedent back in nineteen ninety they
are being met and basically did exactly
the same thing giving a green light for
what became known as devastating so you
are aware of that are you I'm aware of
the history site i'm not going to get
ahead of where we are and make a
hypothetical legal analysis about a
decision that hasn't been maybe actually
you see this as some sort of an
endorsement is it not I'm not going to
use that word site we think it's a
strong statement and I'm not going to go
any further y'all got you on the issue
of crystal clear because you keep saying
crystal clear but so far what we have
seen our video is supplied by a party to
the combat what we have seen that you
keep stating that only lucerne regime
has the rocket capability and so on so
it all seems to be conjectural it seems
to be circumstantial not be not
circumstantial evidence that the regime
maintains custody of these kind of
weapons we have a broad array of
information that points to that that
they that they are the only ones that
have the capability to use these kind of
rockets and delivery systems that the
opposition does not have those
capabilities and I would add to that
before I get to your next question that
we've already had a high confidence
assessment from our intelligence
community that the regime has used
chemical weapons during this conflict so
as I said the intelligence community
will be sharing additional information
about what
realize this assessment but I think that
any assertion that the opposition could
be behind this just defies logic okay so
from your point of view what is what's
useful purpose are they you and
investigators serving if you have
already arrived at a you know beyond a
shadow of any doubt the conclusion that
the regime has already used chemical
weapons what's useful purpose do they
serve and then why do you enter sir yes
ma'am because apparently awaiting
arrived at that conclusion before they
before they submit their report well I'd
make a couple points the first as I said
yesterday was let's keep in mind what
the Mandate of the UN investigation team
is it's not to determine culpability
it's to determine whether chemical
weapons are used which again there that
was determined barish very shortly after
it happened and that even today we saw
the area of the UN investigation was
supposed to go visit it's being attacked
by the syrian regime so they've had to
postpone their investigation so we think
it's important that the regime not be
able to use the investigation is a
stalling tactic or a charade to hide
behind under this notion that they
somehow didn't perpetrate this attached
so why then why do I go through existing
society of sending the the inspector the
UN inspectors if you order it concluded
that there there what use of chemical
weapons and they are not to determine
who did what correct well we clearly
value the UN's work we've said that from
the beginning when it comes to
investigating chemical weapons in Syria
and it's obviously up to the UN to make
their decisions about their team and
when they will attempt to go investigate
even when they won't but we've reached a
point now where we believe too much time
has passed for the investigation to be
credible and that it's clear the
security situation isn't safe for the
team in Syria so again we don't want the
regime to be able to use the UN
investigation as a stalling tactic to
hide behind things that they should
leave well they shouldn't carry on I
mean do you think that what they are
doing or not doing as the case may be
since they seem to be stuck in the hotel
is his a stalling stalling tactic and
therefore they should be pulled out of
the country well the Secretary has been
in close contact with secretary general
view and I'm not going to specifically
detail what those conversations out lied
we've made
views known publicly and privately that
we believe that the UN investigation a
it's not safe for them on the ground and
be that we believe too long of a time
has passed for them to be spurred to be
credible so we made those beautiful it's
you're not pushing for them to go back
and look at some of these areas where
the weapons are supposed to be abused uh
you don't see the point to we believe
that it's too late to be credible
correct but usually they make their own
decisions about their teammate I
understand but I mean you don't think
that it would be helpful for them to
prevent a report especially considering
the fact that they're not going to
determine culpability even the best even
in the best case scenario that would not
be helpful in trying to bring about
people like the Russians who helpfully
convincing them that this has actually
happened we do believe it it's too late
I just want to follow up on the Lavrov
call many the did the secretary and
foreign minister Lavrov do you know did
they discuss this postpone meeting what
the reason i asked my daughter when were
the Russians told that you guys would
not be sending anyone to pay I don't
know the answer i believe it was last
night i do not know if they discussed it
today let me check and see if i can
share ok and then with your quibble over
cancellation versus postpone this
meeting was to be held on the
twenty-eighth correct correct it's been
postponed and they are working to
reschedule it for an additional but the
meeting is no longer happening on the
28th is that correct correct so really I
just I I just meant fight I just not
sure I understand what what what you're
what you're cool with what your quibble
is because if there was going to be a
weeding that was scheduled on the 28 and
we can go back to meeting say in other
cities like Jericho for example but if
there was going to be a meeting yeah if
there was going to be a meeting and then
you guys decided not to have it if there
was going to be a meeting on a certain
date and you decided not to happen
I do think the word difference is
important here in letting you but wait a
second reading that was on the twenty
eighth of august it's not happen it's
not happening it is posted a medium will
be happening very soon at a date we
determined it did was that subject of
the conversation reform in history i do
not know i can attempt to find out I
don't know but I the reason I think is
important let me underscore this is
because I think there have been some
people who have been taken from this
postponement that maybe we're not fully
invested in the Geneva process that
we're walking away from the process with
the Russians even though clearly it's a
difficult time in a difficult situation
and nothing could actually be further
from the truth so I want to underscore
that we are fully invested in working
with the Russians even as we disagree on
a lot in Syria today and I think that
actually is a very important item this
podium that you could assure us that no
meetings have been canceled is that
correct man I'm not even going to go
there today not even going to go there
this meeting has been posted I
appreciate the effort that was a good
one no that's gonna start at the Embassy
oh yes that chemical weapons were you do
you know what kind what time came for
what were you is it's aaron is if nerve
gas is it even worse than that i don't i
don't have additional details about that
Syed again the intelligence community
will be sharing as many additional
details as we can in the coming days
okay are we liked it to have like a
state but perhaps and then maybe today
maybe tomorrow that at least some some
sort of an appellate record that'd be
classified or candy and now is that
likely to happen i don't have any
specifics on timing i will say that once
the intelligence community is prepared
to make its formal assessment we will
provide a classified assessment to the
congress and we will make and
unclassified details available to the
public and that i can say that we will
certainly be making those findings
public this week i don't have additional
time line beyond that
the United States could hear Syria as
early as Thursday which quotes by a
senior official so do you have any
comments on that and some net analysis
day if this drug happens the United
Stated take a different formula strike
from Iraq war may be drawn or okay Amy's
house first well I make I make two
points the first being that the
president hasn't made a decision yet on
how to respond I would underscore that I
would bold it and underline it and
highlight it for all of you today he has
not made a decision yet I know there's a
lot of rumors out there but let's not
get ahead of where the president is on
this the second point I would make is
that I would like to be clear that any
options that we're considering would be
a response to the CW attack at these
Wu's that were not contemplating any
action that would be for example I know
people have asked about this in the
pasture aimed at regime change nothing
like that it's a direct response to CW
you can I ask why not though I mean your
stated policy goal from President Obama
two years ago almost the day it might
even be the actual one-year two-year
anniversary but that President Assad
should go so what you're if you're we
continue to believe that President Assad
has lost all legitimacy and that he
should go any specific action taken in
response to the CW attack will be again
in response to that attack we will
continue helping the opposition gain
strength on the ground but I think we've
made clear that there's no military
solution to this conflict and that's
exactly why we remain fully invested in
the Geneva process but I mean in fact I
think this was the subject of a Wall
Street Journal article or a pen today I
mean don't you if you want to prevent
the use of chemical weapons again don't
you just need to eliminate the source of
the government well that's a very broad
statement of lace woody what exactly do
you mean by the source I mean if you're
saying that the regime used chemical
weapons and you need to respond to these
chemical weapons and you want to prevent
them from happening again why not just
get rid of Assad in your response why
why shouldn't the ultimate response be
to stop them from ever being used by
this regime again again the president
hasn't made
decision he will be making one so that
it could be regime change I I just said
very clearly that we are not
contemplating any action aimed at regime
change but I don't understand why not
them because we're not did you say and I
forgive me because I did you say that it
was aimed at whatever the response is
going to be it is aimed at deterring
future use of chemical weapons I think
how does it positive I think as we get
closer to a response clearly that's one
thing that people are talking about
clearly we want to deter future use of
chemical can I thank you so I wouldn't I
wouldn't disagree with that notion okay
was that also the aim called the first
of the response to the first time that
you had documented evidence of a
chemical weapons attack I think when we
announced our policy change we said that
we were increasing our assistance to the
opposition to help them grow stronger on
the ground in in their fight against the
Assad regime so why why wasn't it then
after the Assad regime had to your
understanding shown itself willing and
able to use chemical weapons why wasn't
your response to the first time
something that you thought would be a
deterrent to the use to a second or
third or fourth years well I'm not
saying that it wasn't actually I think
that clearly we want to take actions
that would deter the regime from using
chemical weapons in the future and what
we saw here with a gross escalation of
the use of chemical weapons not saying
that it wasn't part of the the decision
that went into increase the scale on the
scope of the assistants then well if it
wasn't or if it was you're saying I mean
can you say four can you say positively
whether it was whether that was one of
the goals of the response the first time
around I think that's certainly been a
goal of ours all along and i would say
that about this oh yes ok so the
schedule can we assume that these that
the range of options the president is
considering now start above the level of
increasing the size and the scope and
scale of the of the of your support for
the opposition given the fact that
deterrence was one of your goals the
first time around
and it clearly clearly didn't work I
think it's fair to say that we've been
clear that this was a mass escalation
and chemical weapons use and that we are
going to be making a decision the
president is on an appropriate response
so I think that's a very I think I'd
affair which I think Matt would you
willing to be would you be willing to
concede that your response to the first
documented case of chemical weapons use
was not effective as a deterrent to the
Assad regime using chemical weapons
again well clearly clearly we have now
assess that the Assad regime did use
chemical weapons again now i know i just
got two more and these are very brief
there on the calls i just want to make
sure his calls this morning both of them
with anything other than syria discuss
with lavrov that you're aware of i don't
know i haven't gotten a full readout of
that i will check on that and if we can
give you a more fulsome the moroccan
paul was about Syria or seriously here
was discussed yes why all this talk
about response wanna just take the
response well at some point the
president will be making a decision it
just seems these are very serious issues
and we need to calibrate and discuss and
debate any potential response very
carefully with another one security team
doesn't sound as if you're calibrating
at all I mean all we hear is that
there's going to be a response there's
going to be a response I mean why do you
have to keep telling us or anybody that
there's going to be a response why don't
you just warn the Syrians and make your
response because the president hasn't
made a decision about an appropriate
response yet we so it's going to be
talked about some hyper and you and you
keep saying that you don't want to talk
about some hypothetical decision that
wasn't made but you definitely do seem
to be talking about some hypothetical
response that hasn't been decided on I
have been clear that we are going the
present is going to make a decision on a
response let's remember this attack
didn't take place that long ago we've
been gathering information we have been
working obviously with the UN at first
to see with the UN investigation to see
if they would be granted access they
weren't we've been gathering information
in the day since and we put an
assessment together this didn't happen
you know three months ago it just
happened recently in any response it's a
very it's an important decision that the
President national security team
certainly don't take lightly and they
don't make quickly just to comport with
what people with the timeline in which
people think it should be made I'm not
saying that it should be any specific
timeline but you definitely seem to be
talking a lot about some hypothetical
response yeah so I mean why don't you
just I mean I just don't understand
while that you know there's just a lot
of public talk about it that's because
you keep asking me questions about our
result in all the events that the
administration and and the Secretary to
come down yesterday you make you I know
and to be clear hit a lot of his
statement wasn't about a response it was
about the international norms that were
violated it was about the grotesque a
situation that it happened here it was
about the Assad regime failing to stand
by what they said and give access to you
and so his statement wasn't all about a
response but it made clear that we will
respond absolutely no could you explain
to us as deterrence also includes
neutralizing the capacity the technical
capacity of the regime has launch
control weapons I'm not going to get
into that level of detail about what
potential outcomes might come from out
of this decision but you do I sign the
final responsibility for launching any
chemical attack with the President of
Syria Bashar lesson correct correct yes
okay so a man with the reason he
currently is actually an actual target
he could be a natural time I did not as
part of that deterrent I did not say
that I said that we are not
contemplating any action aimed at regime
change ok so don't don't take those
words okay three steps down the road and
they're going to I'm to understand
clarify because he's at the end of the
day he did the Syrian maker he the
person that is going to continue to
launch or not the lunch so should he or
should he not be emitting the time I'm
not going to answer that question that
way Saeed I have said that we are not
contemplating any action that aimed at
regime change and I'm just not going to
go any further on even though that's
what's Dana's policy goal I mean that's
your stated policy goal so what you're
saying is any action that you're going
to take is not in line with your stated
policy goal of the Sun leaving up I
would strongly disagree with that at
least we have been clear that our policy
goal is Assad leaving office and that
needs to
happen through a political solution
through a Geneva like process that we're
working through right now is our policy
below that I mean by all accounts has
absolutely made no progress since you
started this whole process I don't even
know how long ago was I mean what
progress have you made since since
secretary Kerry and foreign minister
Lavrov first since the first Geneva
meeting what progress has been made in
getting the two sides to come together
well I think a couple points I would
point to clearly we all know this is a
difficult process and again this isn't
going to happen just overnight because
it's the best thing for the Syrian
people when the foreign Minister Lim for
minister Lavrov was here for the 2+2 he
and secretary Kerry reaffirmed their
commitment to a Geneva like process and
said they would continue working
together on it we've seen a couple of
other things happen in the past months
one is that the opposition has elected
leaders we saw that as a key step
towards determining representation for
Geneva Convention obviously we all know
that representation and attendance has
been one of the outstanding issues on
Geneva and Wendy Sherman ambassador Ford
and others have continued working with
the UN and the Russians to make progress
clearly progress is going to be slow
this is a very complicated situation in
for easy it would have been done months
ago but we're very committed and
invested in the process though but what
about getting the two sides the regime
and the opposition together I mean
you're a lot of a lot goes that's a very
simple way of talking about Geneva a lot
goes into getting to that point all of
those little nitpicky things are being
worked through right now with us and the
Russians in the UN it's not just
flipping a switch and saying regime
opposition come to Geneva for a
conference we want to have a conference
at the right time when we feel it can be
most successful because that's
ultimately what's in the best interest
of the Syrian people and we're just not
there yet but we continue working with
the Russians in the UN I know you think
this latest undeniable action by the by
the regime kind of makes the likelihood
of the opposition sitting down with them
highly and the problem not at all i
think it actually underscores the
importance of the political process and
why there is no military solution here I
not get underscores why we need to work
through a political process to end this
exact bloodshed in Syria if you do do
attack which looks looks like it will
happen that a political solution will be
you know that they were just won't be
that interesting coming to the table
that in in the end will be a military
solution well I our position has not
changed that we don't believe there's a
military solution here that any response
again which I will say decision has not
been made on it's aimed at responding to
the CWA use but our position on the
ultimate necessity of a political
solution has not changed here Maria is
as a result of human second has a
response is a response and that's the
the president is considering a limited
to military force he's looking at a wide
range of options I'm not going to
further catalog that for you I think
we've been clear for a year that the
president has a variety of military
contingencies on his desk options for
Syria that he can that he can take if he
chooses to do so but i'm not going to
categorize it and put that way and
there's one more and could present could
the presence of of the UN team on the
ground in Damascus delay or to come into
the be part of the deciding factor on
when I do I don't want to even venture
to guess how that my plane to some sort
of hypothetical short of your response
to the last question there is one option
that has been ruled out as a deterrent
know there is one option that has been
ruled out Oh boots on the ground yes
correct right okay night so I can't read
my notes I apologize so I want to ask
you type as good did you well did you
did you say you welcome the Arab League
decision is that exactly yeah the state
i'm sorry the statement yes yeah so if
you're welcoming that do you are you at
all disappointed by the responses by the
Russians and the Chinese so far or non
responses to this to you know
if you say that you'd like you've
encouraged people to make strong
statements again condemning this an
Italian are you disappointed do you
think that as has been said numerous
times even in by the previous Secretary
of State that they're on the wrong side
of history by ignoring or choosing to
not not come out and condemn what
happened why I actually I would
reference what the secretary said
yesterday that anybody who perpetrates
this notion or this fall so that that
anybody but the regime could be behind
this needs to check their conscience
right but i want you i would like him
but she's not but since he's not here
and you are to identify who it is that
is that needs to check their conscience
i'm not going to parse that further for
you i will i'm just i'm just not going
to do it matt i will say that we have
it's been clear who's been out there
saying casting doubt on the fact that
the regime they use these chemical
weapons we've also been clear that even
though we have differences of opinion
with some of our partners around the
world including the Russians on Syria
that we will continue talking to them
about it which is clear from the
Secretary's call today the last thing is
that when you say that your goal is not
regime change but you also say we're not
contemplating any action a male regime
change correct in this response right
okay I want to divorce it from this
response the response to the chemicals
your goal though your ultimate goal is
not regime change well we've been clear
that our ultimate I mean a policy goal
our ultimate position is that Assad no
longer has legitimately it must not be
empowered what what does that mean that
anyone whose last name is Assad who's
really in this family cannot be that
kind of cannot cannot be in a leadership
position like it is why for example and
I'm not going to make that broad
statement or generalize in that way at
this point okay so then it really isn't
your goal really isn't an end to the
Assad regime necessarily because someone
else in that family you think good i'm
not i'm not making a comment on that one
way or the other
I'm just not so you're not you're not
looking for the end of the Assad
families tyranny over Syria we've been
clear the Assad regime is odd we have
included a zadra sheet regime excuse me
can no longer be in power it is it has
lost all legitimacy you said I'm not
going to further parse it for even that
I'm just not yet you're speaking about
the political solution and the Geneva 2
conference as I'm sure you're aware that
you went under secretary-general Jeff
Feltman is in Tehran a trip like this is
not very ordinary for a such a high
level you went official especially when
he's an American and it could not have
happen with that consultation with the
US administration what can you tell us
about the purpose behind that truck oh I
actually don't have anything for you on
that I would refer you to the UN as he's
not a US official i have any more
details i'm happy to share them but
again he's not there representing the
United States and I I don't know if I
would actually make the assumption that
you just made I just don't have the
facts about his trip I would not make
that assumption the president is
reviewing a number of options and is not
made a decision yet so the Syrian
government would be held accountable by
by the US through a non-military
response again I there he has a range of
options whatever they are yet well
there's a range of them we've been clear
that some of those include military
contingencies some don't I I'm not going
to know the ones that don't I'm not
going to further parse it for you throw
on his desk and he'll make a decision
when he's ready you mentioned a
classified briefing that would be given
to Congress do you have any more
information on who will be making that
briefing I don't I know if we have more
information to share we can I just don't
have any more information for you right
now and then I was Ellen test um I know
you said you're not going to do any
legal analysis on the president's
forthcoming decision but you're going to
get me to try I'm just leaving that
aside and just focusing exclusively on
the Assad regime's use of chemical
weapons does the administration view
that as a violation of international law
I think we were very clear and secretary
used the word international norms and
actually let me pick through some of the
history on that I think it might be
helpful as we talk about this issue so
thank you for the question there's
clearly a long history to these inner
national norms that goes back many years
and this isn't a comprehensive list but
I'll just make a few points we're going
back after World War one the youth in
which the use of chemical weapons
resulted in nearly a hundred thousand
deaths the geneva protocol was signed in
1925 ratified by 137 states the protocol
prohibited the use of chemical weapons
quote in war in 1997 the Chemical
Weapons Convention entered into force
this multilateral disarmament agreement
provides for the elimination of an
entire category of weapons of mass
destruction under universally applied
international control and for hibbitts
the use of chemical weapons currently a
189 nations which represent about
ninety-eight percent of the global
population have joined the Chemical
Weapons Convention such as the little
history on the international norms here
at work emissary is it correct that
serious the correct that Syria is not a
signatory to that correct there are only
five countries in the world that have
neither signed nor ceded to the
convention but clearly that should not
enable them to escape responsibility for
their actions there is a reason that the
overwhelming majority of the
international community again that
agrees on little else has stood against
the use of these weapons and serious
should not be able to flout the clearly
expressed view of the international
community here you are they modify put
that list of precedents out yeah we'll
send something to the bullpen after the
briefing there was a little more detail
to who are the five that have not either
neither signed nor ceded to the CWC
Angola Egypt North Korea South Sudan and
Syria yes still on Syria yes any
discussion with authorities in Athens
about the possible use of us faces in
Greece on any potential military strike
against Syria I don't have any
additional details for you about
conversations about potential options
that might be part of response since you
brought up the since you brought up the
history I'm just wondering you
if you look back and found when any
previous administration has used as the
use of chemical weapons as a legal
justification for military or any other
intervention I think that I would
strongly discourage people from
comparing the situation to any
historical other situation where
chemical images with the world war no
I'm talking I mean I'm laying out the
historical set of international norms
that have formed you're trying to
compare it to be on vacation or another
and I'm trying to compare it I'm just
asking you if you are aware of any
previous administration relying on the
use of chemical weapons as justification
for a military or non military
intervention I'm just wondering if you
brought it you opened the door to this
going back to points I was laying out
the historical international norm
against the use of chemical weapons
clearly we're all familiar with some of
the history including recent history on
this issue and I'm not going to go into
a further Lee historical analysis than
that what's the occasion I think it's
important to lay out the historical we
did the international norms I'm comers
what Emily you can't just throw it out
there and then say I'm not going to
answer any more fun okay so what's your
neck what's your next question where
were you going with that Matt well I
just wanted i'm not i'm asking you is so
very simple yes yes okay the answer is
yes the previous administrations have
used the use of chemical weapons as the
legal justification for intervention
military or otherwise in the past yeah i
don't know about legal justification but
i know it's been a topic of discussion
and past conflicts yes okay wait can you
which which ones see i'm not going to go
down this rabbit hole with you we are
not comparing this specific case to any
other time we've concluded that a regime
may or may not or whatever the
discussion was about chemical women i
laid out historical basis and
international norm against the use of
chemical weapons are actually two
different things you're trying to take
me down arrival no i'm not your you're
assuming that i'm trying to trick you
again and i'm not going i just don't
really do it's hard to tell
I it's a very straightforward question
are you familiar with any case in which
a previous administration has used this
as the rationale for intervention
military really we're all familiar with
a lot of pastry Matt yet let me as you
are but I'm just asking you what when
because I'm not when we've discussed
chemical weapons in terms of military
intervention in place has been in the
past yeah where has the u.s. intervened
on the basis of a gun country using
chemical weapons I I can't think of one
other problem and I just what you say no
I'm asking you said yes it has happened
so I want a night with it there have
been conversations in the past we all
lived through the past 12 years and we
all remember the discussions about WMD
in the past that's where I thought you
were going with that I'm not going to go
actually that's why I'm not trying to
get you to compare this to a rack or
anything else I just wanted to find out
if you were aware i guess a statement
stands I don't want to compare this to
any previous administrations any
previous version of my question was yes
it has happened so I I'm not comparing
it to any previous administration or
previous decision so I'm not going to
have a discussion we continue this
happen talk here about internet no I
didn't want to be crowded I'm not going
to compare this to anybody emanation
again why did you ask about previous
administrations I'm not wondering if any
if you are aware that any if any
previous administration has used the the
use of chemical weapons as eight I don't
think it's relevant in this case that's
my answer and we're moving on oh thank
you tight go ahead so you don't go to
unicode later I just wanted to ask you
it seems that you have concluded early
on on Wednesday actually right after the
attack the other regime was responsible
for this attack can you explain to us I
know you talked about this before why
did the secretary and take the
initiative and talk to Milan why did you
what did he even if you had already
concluded the regime stands behind it
and the fact that he called him to tell
him that if you had nothing to hide you
should have allowed people in right away
which means he called him right away
what did he call he made a direct demand
to the Syrian regime that if as they
have stated they were not responsible
for these attacks they should allow
investigators and he gave them an
opportunity
to prove to the world what they were
saying publicly and they failed to take
it it's important to make a direct
demanded that in terms of just the
sequel cynical only events when do you
when did you conclude that the Syrians
were behind this and it is not allowed
basically to sort of the destroy
evidence and so on well I think we're
very early on there without a day by
friday but i'll make a few points the
first is the intelligence community will
be sharing more details about their
assessment but broadly speaking there's
been a preponderance of publicly
available information from the very
beginning quite frankly that indicated
there was a mass scale a chemical
weapons attack we've known and assessed
for a long time that the Syrian regime
had the capabilities to do this and the
opposition didn't so obviously we
thought it was important to investigate
to do our own assessment but this is
just common sense at the heart of it
backed up by facts and assessments and
information and intelligence if you li
it's a couple of things first of all
just in response to this just question
right here if you knew that the
administrator regime had all these
chemical weapons and you were afraid
that they were going to use them and
they used them before and you warned
them against crossing a red line and
they cross it then what what actions did
you take to prevent further use in what
regard further use from the regime from
using him again a warning this was a
massive escalation in use we had not
seen this this level of use from this
from the regime in the past I think that
we made clear very strongly the last
time we assessed that they had used them
in small scale incident that they had
crossed a red line and that we were
taking action but again the Syrian
regime has continued at every step to
take the actions that are most hurtful
to their people and that's why the
president is Wayne an appropriate
response in this instance now you talk
about international norms the precedent
for acting no sir do you feel that inner
precedent on international norms is
enough or do you feel that any response
would requires a basis of international
law I'm not going to do any further
hypothetical legal analysis than I
already have here before the president's
made a decision and I just my question
really was are you aware of precedent
or intervention based on the use of
chemical weapons that's all I was at
that I just wanted you what I understand
it a little differently let me take that
question and see if I can get you what I
was trying to get to I was a trying to
go a little differently which is why I
responded the way I did so let me look
into that question see if there's no I'm
Frank I'm honestly not aware of one
there may very well be one I'm just
responds to a specific use of chemical
weapons I think the way you asked and
maybe this is why i was confused with
whether it have been part of a case
broadly speaking for military action in
the past that's all so those are two
different questions i think i will take
it and get you there are actually two
different questions but i will take your
actual question and endeavor to get you
a more fulsome response again marie to
be perfectly clear yesterday you said
the US has very little doubt on the fact
that the regime is responsible for the
ways they attack today you have
absolutely no doubt that Damascus is
behind the attack last week ok and the
French president has just said that the
decision from the US will be taken in
the coming days easy easy correct why I
think we've been clear that we feel a
sense of urgency here to make a decision
but the president hasn't made one yet I
don't want to put any timeline on it
beyond that anything else on Syria yes
ok you said kind of falling on this too
now we're crystal clear and the Intel
community will be providing additional
info within the week my question is what
is the intelligence community doing
between secretary Kerry's statement
which was strong and forceful and I
would assume has the backing of the
intelligence community what you're
saying today and this delay it would
seem why would overall the delay clearly
there's a process to getting classified
assessments to the hill there's a
process to putting together the
unclassified version that will go
publicly I wouldn't call it a delay
there's just a process that's ongoing so
this is dotting T's Crossing eyes type
of thing as there's not new information
coming in it is Sunday I think there's
new information coming in all the time
which is what happens I
when you do Intel assessment but I
wouldn't I wouldn't read anything into
the fact that the assessment won't be
coming except at some point this week I
don't have more with the Saxon will be
coming sometime or to make me make
public but the president has got the
assessment already it's my guess that's
my understanding I don't want to speak
for him on this I want to make sure that
that's actually one hundred percent
accurate but it is my understanding yes
it's my understanding at this point
we're just preparing the classified
assessment to go to the hill I don't
want to get but he's got this again III
don't know exactly about the timing and
I don't want to get ahead of this i'm
not speaking for the icy here so let me
double check and if there's more
specifics to share with you i can't and
then what response would you be seeking
from the hill a an agreement to go to
attack or what what kind of what are you
looking for well the secretary and
others has been in close consultation
with the hill as part of this of the
process and talking about a potential
response i don't have anything further
for what that consultation entails
clearly we think it's important to talk
to Congress about this and it talked
them through the assessment when we
provide the classified assessment as
well yes and then you've stated today
that again that the policy goal of the
united states is to see a political
transition through a Geneva like process
analysts and observers of this have said
that it's unlikely that Assad would come
to the table while he views himself as
winning wouldn't it be Rebecca by Lord
helpful if the response the US takes
turns the battlefield position and would
reverse his gains that he's made
recently well I think it's fair to say
that every step we've taken to assist
the opposition and help them grow in
strength has been to do just that right
it's to help them grow stronger to help
him call us but also to help them be
able to make more gains on the ground so
I think that's been a broad goal from
the beginning and will continue to be
I'm sure with with any eventual decision
that the president so when we're looking
at the
response you've rolled out that this
action would be aimed at regime change
some have said that it could be a
specific response to chemical weapons
use and nothing further than that but my
question is is there an element of it
that would be aimed at helping change
the balance of power on the ground or do
you view responding specifically to a
chemical weapons attack as doing that as
well I think they're probably just you
know any action any decision would
probably meet both objectives but again
no decision has been made yet so we're
going to keep doing things that help the
opposition grow and also respond to this
but again I don't want to get ahead of
what the goals of a response would be
before a decision on what that response
is is actually made many are you aware
that most in fact if not all public
polls showed that the American people by
a very large majority opposed to any
kind of intervention should that factor
in in any kind of decision I think the
president's been clear that he makes
decisions about our national security
based in what's best for national
security interest of this country and I
think it's clear here that there are
core national security interests at
stake for the united states clearly the
mass scale use of chemical weapons or
potential proliferation of these weapons
flagrantly violates an important
international norm and therefore
threatens american security it's also
worth keeping in mind that this is
taking place in in a region that is
already destabilized it is taking place
in a country the borders and ally of the
United States and Turkey and a close
friend and partner of the United States
in Jordan so it's important that the
United States and the international
community send a strong message because
it's in our national security interests
to do so and that's what guys the
president's decision-making on these
issues sorry I missed one of the
country's does Israel not matter of
course its realize I'm closest friend
and now I in the region they don't but
they didn't merit I mentioned in the
talking points clearly are we how about
Lebanon talk all of the country we have
been clear that Syria and spill up
violence from Syria has been
destabilizing for the entire region
including Lebanon including Iraq I just
mentioned two countries here but I've
talked at length about the disastrous
effects that Syria is having on other
countries in the region as well and you
would argue as well in the president
would I assume the administration I
assume everyone in the administration
would argue that simply that jut would
quite apart from any interest that your
allies the interests of your allies in
the region and quite apart from the
threat of proliferation should that the
acts just the use of the death of Syrian
civilians on such a mass scale is also
countered a u.s. national interest is
that correct absolutely and if it
continued chaos in Syria is it one
moment on the fact that I'm sorry I want
to make that clear okay I just wanted to
ask you if you have any comments on the
statement by the Iraqi government that
they will not allow any kind of
overflight beat by airplanes or fighter
jets or cruise missiles to go over their
airspace into Syria by the Americans are
you aware that well I actually haven't
seen those comments I'd but I also don't
want it don't think anyone should get
ahead of where the president is and
whether or not a decisions been made it
and start talking about hypotheticals
anything else on Syria yes the
assessment of additional information
that caused you to change your
confidence level from very little down
to crystal clear when did that
assessment come out with it this morning
or in whole I wouldn't point to a
specific assessment as i said the
intelligence community assessment it
will be forthcoming publicly sometime
this week I think we've continued
gathering information and got to a point
where we felt comfortable today publicly
saying that that the Syrian regime is
responsible for the use of chemical
weapons in this in this situation and
again from day one common sense would
lead anybody to believe that but we did
our due diligence and we're looking into
it and more details will be coming from
the intelligence community point right
now publicly to what it was that got rid
of that one scintilla of doubt well I
think that's the preponderance of
evidence and again the details of the
intelligence assessment will be coming
in the coming days but I think the fact
that only one side in this conflict has
the ability to change this and n1
doesn't is a huge part of that but yes
the specifics on the
it will be coming Pacific thing that
made that got you over that last tick
from eleven fifty nine to midnight I'm
sure positive positivity will you're not
in a position to say what it was right
now I'm not gonna be that will be part
of these okay we won I don't be going
good luck I just want to get ya know
okay let's move on and then with
management I just wanted to go to Egypt
to see how the is anyone paying
attention to Egypt right now or is
everyone focused on Syria and if if
there are people paying attention to
Egypt where what's the status of the
review create review because we have
more people on the hill calling for
suspension well clearly everybody is
still very focused on each as I said
that the secretary spoke yesterday with
the Egyptian Foreign Minister and quite
frankly in a lot of these discussions
Egypt is discussed as well clearly
everybody is focused on both I have no
update for you on timing of a decision
on the review of assistance at this
point acuity absent from this discussion
over the technical what disease Masseria
in what way in many ways they know how
do you define are you Russian are you
discussing with them the consequence of
this chemical attack with the Egyptian
yes well the secretary spoke with the
Egyptian Foreign Minister yesterday I
don't have a more fulsome readout of
that call but clearly we're talking to
all of our partners in the region about
about the use of chemical weapons in
Syria also about the situation in Egypt
so you feel that Egypt is sort of unluck
stood with you on the issue of the
chemical weapons like that is not at all
what I said I'm not going to categorize
the Egyptian interim government's
position on the chemical weapons use in
Syria one way or the other that's for
them take care of it certainly Egypt is
a very major ally and its position would
mean a lot to you wouldn't it well I
think all of we take all of our partners
positions seriously that's why the
Secretary's engage with them on the
phone on a regular basis at the same
time satiate as you know we are
currently reviewing our entire
relationship with the Egyptian
government including assistance and
determining the best way to move that
relationship forward
point is are you looking for bilateral
for individual Arab countries to come
out in support of a response whatever it
is or is the Arab League a blanket that
enough for you well certainly we believe
that the Arab League is an incredibly
important organization to come out so
publicly it only but we also would
welcome of course anybody rule
individual countries anybody coming out
and condemning this use it and and
indicated that there should be
accountability in the situation yes
nothing Egypt I it looks like that
focusing on I mean I I know that math
asked the same question but somehow i
try to phrase it in a different way
maybe I wish I it's a different answer
may be as long it's not hypothetical you
know it's like things are going on on
the ground and we are talking about here
about the entire review entirely
reviewing the relations are you I mean
trying to do anything or just wait and
see what's going on to happen and
accordingly we decide what we can do I
mean from here to there because I mean
things are going on on the ground and
it's it's really clear that more
decisive decisions are making by the
interim government and more people are
arrested more media outlets are closed
and and so on and so on is there
anything going on from this side or just
watching and waiting till let's finish
it's our plate full of Syria now let's
finish this food and then we can find
another thing later not at all I think
that everybody is still very focused as
well I'm what's happening on the ground
in Egypt that's playing into our ongoing
review clearly we're focused on Syria
too but nobody has stopped paying
attention to what's going on on the
ground that's all part of what we're
reviewing right now and will feed into
an eventual decision on what our
relationship will look like going
forward yeah but the question is I know
that one of the favorite expression in
this time
is that I can walk in to do I was going
to say that but you do it I mean it's
one of this state department lexicon you
know what you call it walked right into
that one go ahead so I'm trying to
figure out if you are talking a
following what's going on in Egypt what
you what is your observation what your
criteria what you are doing I mean it's
like because it seems that it's not
exactly moving in the same way that you
were wishing or willing or participating
or expecting well I think we've been
clear that the actions the interim
government has taken and continues to
take in some cases have forced us to
reevaluate this entire relationship and
we've made it clear when they've taken
steps that aren't moving Egypt back
towards an inclusive sustainable
democracy so obviously that that's all
playing into our assessment and our
review and when we have an announcement
to make we will it's making its I think
to that point is this are you in the
process of making a determination or
completing some review or is this a
dynamic fluid situation where it's not
time to make such a determination we are
in the process of undertaking a review
clearly at some point the president will
make a decision about our broad
relationship but also about some of the
assistants decisions we've talked about
in this room so that reviews on going
we're not in wait and see mode we're
looking at all of that right now I want
to move on to the peace process but
before I do I just want to remind you
that neither Israel nor minima are
signatory to the Kim away with it I will
correctly so both Israel and Burma has
signed but have not yet ratified to see
wml road I said there were five
countries only that had not signed nor
is seated to it they have both signed it
moving on to the peace process anything
that you can share with us about the
meeting yesterday I don't have any
updates for you on that can you tell us
why the Palestinians keep saying that
they are both tied and get both kotik
but then lo and behold they did attend
the meeting I'd refer you to the
Palestinians to explain their record did
anyone from this building or
from elsewhere talk to the Palestinians
and say that you better go to the
meetings I'm not going to give you any
more details about our discussions with
the parties in these negotiations so
nothing there Fleck to boycott the
meeting was not discussed by any
American official with any possible
absolutely not what I said Syed I said
I'm not going to discuss any of our
private discussions with either side as
part of this negotiation and lastly when
is the next round expected I don't have
any announcements for you on that this
is something that the secretary remains
focused on metra absolutely so Egypt
Syria Israelis Palestine how about the
Arctic whales the secretary is remain
South China Sea fully engaged the
plethora of issues that come to his
plate every day focused on all of them
he's clearly mad he said that uh Syria
this week he was clear yes all that
water that what had happened in Syria
was a serious priority and with the top
priority can I just ask you there was a
plethora of interest is able to focus on
a number of things he's an extraordinary
man amazing um there was a report
yesterday or the day before I that
camera when it was it said that the
State Department was saying now that the
review the Keystone review would not be
done until 2014 is that correct I think
we've been clear from the beginning that
we don't have a timeline we haven't put
a timeline on when the review will be
done we are as i said before reviewing
the application in a rigorous
transparent and efficient manner manner
but we've never put a timeline on it and
I don't have one for you now okay but
that's not entirely true there was a
timeline put on it before I mean people
had talked about the EIA I mean not a
decision but in terms of the ein terms
of the environmental impact statement
and the wreath we redo of the EIS after
the roots what I'm referring to i think
that supports referred to it the final
the final uhh well maybe I misread it
but I thought it was about the i'm not i
realized that the final decision will
you know the president is delegated but
it will come in but i'm talking about
the environmental impact
yeah the final will be root again will
be released after additional analysis
and the issues identified in all of the
public comments have been incorporated
that process is ongoing I believe
there's over 1.2 million if that numbers
correct that takes it takes a while but
it's my understanding that we haven't
put a timeline on that in do you have
any idea how many of the millions of our
many million comments it is have been
gone through I mean do you know where in
the process they are are they still
going through the comments have they
gone through the comments and they're
incorporating them into the report now
let me get some more details for you on
that i actually just don't know the
answer i know there's a team of people
looking into this right I just don't
know but it is not correct or it is
correct that the State Department has
said that it won't be finished until
night 2014 not not to my knowledge and
that's my knowledge and again I'm not
putting a timeline on it here okay but a
report that said that you that the State
Department has said that it won't be
finished until 2014 would not be correct
I that's my understanding yes I
certainly never said it thank you thank
you